this week we're partnered up with Harry
is helping us look good guys keep it
down I know we're late to this trailer
but in all fairness this crap was
supposed to come out on Sunday we're
gonna watch the trailer for a quiet
place St Uno it's the Mexico version
because you always got to do one of them
spin-offs quiet place day Mexico
anyway uh that's my joke for today just
getting warmed up people leave a like on
this video I'm glad they released this
cuz they knew they can't compete with
Deadpool 3 Let's
[Music]
Go Memory Lane God remember that first
trailer I was like this guy from The
Office seems so
serious
right
kill so loud
damn quiet place loud as
day oh this is straight up Cloverfield
Vibes now yeah
totally
ah damn
whoa
please
please oh that thing was about to
crush wo oh oh it's Joseph
Quinn okay
yeah that is
damn oh
Jamon
YY oh his
wife
o actually that wouldn't make
sense I right he's in the the last uh
whoa
whoa he's encountered stranger things
before I did that was clever that was
clever man I do got some thoughts on it
though John positives I got some concern
what but you know what I'm not concerned
about our awesome sponsor Harry's
thrilled to be partnering with a brand
I've been using for nearly two years now
and that's Harry's Razors I'm generally
more drawn to anything that goes against
the norm and Harry's does just that in
The Grooming World they saw the high
prices in the industry and decided to
blaze their own trail with quality and
affordability I keep a beer but whenever
you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right
there keeps my wife happy and Harry's
makes it effortless they're Precision
Blades that cut smoothly with less drag
making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile
for other areas too you know what I mean
so as a hary dvoa can vouch for their
value you can experience unparalleled
comfort and quality in your grooming
routine where exceptional craftsmanship
meets affordability making a smart
choice for a top notot shave without
breaking the bank their kits and value
packs for shaving are unbeatable but
haries is not just about shaving again
they offer top quality thoughtfully
designed grooming products including
shampoo conditioner and amazing body
wash without the premium price quality
affordability that's a thesis of this
now these I actually pulled right from
my own bathroom I regularly use their
five blade razor with a nice weighted
handle and their foaming shave gel man
this that oh it is a game changer I just
like the feel of it now I have to commit
to keeping this in my hand the whole
time cuz I'm not going to go to the
bathroom in the middle of shooting this
the handles they feel perfectly balanced
and the razor Sleek design is a classy
addition to my bathroom and the quality
of the shave unparalleled got to
reiterate key part of my weekly grooming
ritual cuz their entire range of
products fits seamlessly into my routine
definitely no re-shoot here their German
engineer blades are durable and refill
plans are economical rarely use the word
economical but I'm using it now plus
their commitment to high customer
satisfaction and no risk trial makes
Harry's a no-brainer this Joe really
does feel good let me say once more
choosing Harry's means quality and
affordability by grabbing your $13 trial
set for just $3 at harry's.com reject
you're not only getting a great deal but
you're also supporting this channel
that's harry's.com reex for your three
trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry till next time
reject Nation till next time wow that
trailer was the antithesis to what we
know as what a quiet place to be you
know it makes sense though it's day one
and in day one I like it seen in like a
you know Mass City because the the other
two movies they take place in more of a
small town flare and to have it be a big
city of course no one's going to know
likeone just shut
up yeah what's happening it's just going
enter of chaos and pandemonium and it's
going to take a while for people to
figure out oh we just going to keep it
down all of our stuff is so noisy and we
are noisy people so I I think it's a
very effective trailer it really reminds
me of things like especially Cloverfield
um and then you know I get like War of
the World you know big alien invasion
is what it feels like and while I
thought the trailer was very effective
I'm excited for leita yongo I think
she's a very talented actress and uh
this director don't know who it is but I
I think there I think it's it was cool
to like oh let's really change it up
here and see what differences we can
bring with making an effective Invasion
sci-fi thriller Joseph Quinn this is his
typ casting now this genre you know
crawly alien creatures invading the
world except this time he's going to
play in every man instead of a lovable
freak yeah and Jamon hansu uh having the
connective threat cuz he is in the last
one right I believe second yeah yeah
it's the second one uh it's on that
island they find having that connector
threat I think is is a is a good
call my one concern because while this
is a great 90 seconds my one concern is
that it it does feel like the complete
antithesis to the vibe and atmosphere
that
is often the thing that rock and rolls
with the Quiet Place movies that makes
it an effective experience when you're
in that theater and you know that rare
time room was like oh I guess I got
to not like not eat my popcorn loud
unless you're Aaron Alexander true story
uh
but Alexander most people you know you
want to be quiet we're here it's like
all right debox let's go you IMAX
here so that's like the one thing like I
I just feel like it might not feel like
a quiet place well and it is a Trope
certainly of of uh any horror movie that
happens to take place outside of a big
city at a certain point if we're making
more of these we got to go to the big
city uh so I can Al also Imagine a whole
bunch of homages to different things
happening due to that um but you know
it's cool in the context and and
switching it up to see you know like a
the bridge collapsing and and just
seeing what these what kind of Havoc
these creatures can reach in places
where buildings go that high up um and
so yeah like you know this is just a
glimpse and mostly I'm just excited for
like the cast and I think like
Cloverfield is a perfect set of Vibes to
pull in for something like this because
you know they they both have both
Cloverfield and a quiet place in their
own way have a Twilight zoney quality
along with all the other you know sci-fi
Mayhem that they're pulling in obviously
Twilight Zone not being like action
oriented necessarily but uh yeah and
centering around Lupita nango like I
don't know much about the story they
have here but it looks like she's just
like living on the street as this is
happening or something and uh I don't
know it seems like a very she's Emily
Blunt's biological sister oh of course I
should have recognized
her I can't tell here in this in this
shot if she's just covered in debris but
she kind of looks like she's just been
living out on the street and I feel like
that's kind of an interesting
perspective or or character to follow uh
because it looks like you have her in
her position and then him like you know
some kind of you know corporate yeah
some kind of suicide as some kind of
corporate dude oh so corporate guy
helping homeless person oh 1centers vers
in the bottom of the financial pole but
really it'll be her who saves his ass
and then Jon hunts who will save them
both because we know he makes it to the
next two movies I have a feeling this
cat gonna die I'm a little afraid for
the cat it be like and now yeah and then
that's yeah you can't keep the cat quiet
it's messed up but overall yeah this
looks like a really cool movie yeah look
cool I feel like all you have to nail is
is yeah just like the immediacy and the
intensity and and some good sound mixing
some good sound design yeah and half the
battle is done I'm just saying guys if
it wasn't called a quiet place you would
you think it would just be another like
yeah it looks like a solid look like an
alien movie yeah yeah totally totally
totally if you remove us from
the rural you know Backwoods and stuff
like that yeah yeah say like you know
come on guys come on TRS are cool but
you know no sure this will be a very fun
be fine and that is the funny thing of
like doing doing day one for this
scenario is like what makes quiet place
kind of unique is that yeah you are
living under the circumstances brought
forth by this Invasion and so yeah
seeing the first day of the invasion is
just sort of like yeah it's an invasion
well I guess my
with such a big military operation in
place to protect a large populated area
you know the the the deaf girl she was
able to dial up the radio Notch and
then you think that uh they they might
just stumble upon that we have a lot of
like AAL weapons and stuff like that so
yeah you know I mean I guess we always
lead with artillery but like you know
I'm sure we have very many like you know
Soundwave machines or or stuff that
we've seen on experimental military Tech
shows or whatever yeah anyway uh I
thought it was solid what did you guys
think leave your thoughts down below uh
be sure to leave a like subscribe and uh
we will catch you guys very very
[Music]
soon